In the previous part of this lesson, we saw
what ‘refraction of light’ is!
It’s
simply the bending of light when it travels
from one medium to another!
The
question I left you with was “Why does light
change its direction after
entering another medium at an angle?”
Let’s discuss that in detail.
The change in direction of light occurs because
of
the CHANGE IN THE SPEED of light in THAT MEDIUM.
When light enters another medium, there is
a CHANGE IN ITS SPEED.
The
speed may either increase or decrease depending
on the medium.
Note that
when we say that the speed will increase,
it does NOT mean that the speed will
be greater than THIS value, which is the speed
of light in vacuum.
It means that
its speed in the refractive medium will be
greater than its speed in the incident
medium.
Similarly, the decrease in speed is also in
comparison with the speed
in the incident medium.
When the light is entering into the glass
at an angle, it travels at a lesser speed
than in air... and when it goes from glass
to air, its speed increases.
So it is because of this change in speed that
the direction of light changes!
But what if light is entering PERPENDICULAR
to the surface of the glass?
Will its
speed change?
Yes, its speed will change, however it does
not bend this time.
Yes, the refracted ray propagates in the same
direction as the incident ray.
Talking about the case when light enters at
an angle… there is one more
observation that we can make.
Observe this part of the refraction.
Observe the incident and refracted rays!
We notice that the refracted ray is more towards
the normal than the incident
ray.
When the light ray enters the glass from air,
it bends… and it bends
TOWARDS the normal.
And from this refraction, we can see that
when the light
ray again enters the air, it bends AWAY from
the normal.
So we can say that when the light travels
from an OPTICALLY RARER MEDIUM
to an OPTICALLY DENSER MEDIUM, it bends TOWARDS
the normal and when
the light travels from an optically denser
medium to an optically rarer medium,
it bends AWAY from the normal.
Optically rarer to Optically denser  Bends
towards the normal
Optically denser to Optically rarer  Bends
away from the normal
What do we mean by optically rarer and denser
mediums by the way?
An optical medium is a medium through which
light can propagate.
Since both
air and glass are transparent, light can pass
through them.
So,both of them are
optical mediums.
What about rarer and denser?
If the refractive medium is optically rarer
compared to the incident medium, then the
speed of light in it will be greater!
And when the refractive medium is optically
denser compared to the incident
medium, the speed of light in it will be lesser.
Note than in both cases, we are
comparing the speed of light with the speed
of light in the incident medium!
So what do we understand by this?
How can we summarise it?
When light is travelling from an optically
rarer medium to an optically denser
medium, its speed will decrease and it will
bend TOWARDS the normal.
Whereas, when the light is travelling from
an optically denser medium to an
optically rarer medium, its speed will increase
and it will bend AWAY from the
normal.
Optically rarer to Optically denser  Speed
decreases , Bends towards the normal
Optically denser to Optically rarer  Speed
indcreases , Bends away from the normal
Now that this is clear, I want you to understand
another concept!
Now instead of a glass slab, we have water,
and also suppose that the ray of
light is incident in the same direction.
We can see that this angle is the same in
both the cases!
So will the refracted ray in this case travel
in this direction only?
In other
words, will the angle of refraction be the
same in both cases?
No the angle of refraction will be different
in this case.
In fact the angle of
refraction here is greater than the previous
one.
So what can we infer?
We can say that the refraction of a light
ray depends on
the MATERIAL MEDIUM on which light is incident.
Yes, light rays will be
refracted by different amounts in different
materials.
But wait…
I have a couple of questions for you!
Talking about the case when
light enters at an angle… how does the change
in speed result in the change in
direction of light?
And why does this perpendicular ray not change
its direction
after refraction?
I know that you must be curious to know the
answers!
However we’ll understand this in the next
video.
It’s really interesting, make
sure you watch it!